- [Narrator] This is no 4th of July.
This is the national pyrotechnic festival
in Tultepec, Mexico.
(upbeat music)
Each year, the city throws
the Pamplonada Pirotécnia
or National Pyrotechnic Festival
for nine days in March
to celebrate the feast
of John of God, the patron
saint of firework-makers.
Local families, businesses,
and firework factories
build enormous bull-shaped floats
out of paper mache called torritos,
the construction of which can take months.
The exterior of these floats
are completely covered with
decorations and fireworks.
This is all in preparation
for the festival's most popular event,
the burning of the bulls.
The bulls are paraded through the town
and brought into the
square in front of crowds
chanting (fuego) or fire.
A courageous soul is then sent in
to light up each float.
As the bulls are pulled
through the fearless crowd
the fireworks illuminate the town
and the party rages on into the night.
(upbeat music)
(electronic music)